hi everyone and welcome to my
presentation my name is george norev i'm
a second year phd student at penn
advised by michael kearns and aaron roth
this paper is joint work with varan
gupta chris young molesh pai and aaron
roth let's jump straight into it
so what is our paper about in a nutshell
we consider an online contextual setting
and
we provide in the setting
various forms of uncertainty guarantees
we imagine the data points that come to
us at each round
as being
labeled individuals coming from some
population
our
uncertainty guarantees then hold
conditional
on each group in a potentially large and
complex
collection of
subpopulations of this population
our technique
originates from ideas
put forth in the 90s by feudenberg
levine and hart among others
and it is a simple and general tool
that lets us
obtain
many types of uncertainty estimates in a
streamlined fashion
its main component is the fundamental
theorem of game theory known as the min
max theorem
so first of all
why do we need to care about uncertainty
estimation
up until now the dominant branch of
machine learning research has focused on
producing
models
that are more and more accurate
and we have achieved great successes in
this branch
think neural
nets however more recently
we're seeing an increased focus
on
understanding
whether or not
the model can be
made to know
when
it doesn't know the right answer
in other words
when
is the model
at its most uncertain over the entire
sample space
such guarantee is a very important
practice and so
i guess to
give us
some visual imagery to
feed into our imagination
let's consider
a patient and a doctor having a
conversation at the doctor's office
and so the doctor
is telling the patients that given the
patient's features x
the expected disease severity in two
days will be f of x
and the patient
is rightfully interested in knowing how
certain the doctor is such a diagnosis
the doctor might respond i have a 95
prediction interval
which tells me that your diagnosis will
be between
l of x and u of x
however
what does it mean
to have
this kind of prediction interval
the doctor might clarify
that the prediction interval in question
is actually
a marginal prediction interval
what this means
is that the label will fall into this
interval 95 percent of the time
if we sample from the entire
labeled population
notice that we won't be conditioning on
this current patient's features instead
we actually just take the average over
the entire population
however this can be a problematic type
of prediction rules
what can happen for example is that the
learner
is that
the patient sorry can
be part of a very small subpopulation
which comprises maybe one percent of the
entire population
in this case it would be entirely
consistent with this 95 prediction
interval guarantee
that
all of the individuals in this small
subpopulations are completely
misclassified
so therefore the patient decides to dig
a little bit deeper into this
and
asks the doctor to provide more
uncertainty estimates that are specific
to
this patient's features
and the doctor may not have ever
encountered any other patient with the
same type of features as this patient of
course
but
at the same time this doctor might have
seen enough people from
some of the sub-populations that this
patient belongs to so as to make
um an informed guess about
um the confidence of her diagnosis for
those sub-populations and so the doctor
might say well
for african-americans under the age of
50 like you
my 95 prediction interval is a to b
and for women with a family history of
diabetes
my prediction rule will be c to d
and for people with egg allergies my
prediction interval will be e to f
that sounds really cool however once
again we might run into problems for
instance
depending on our uncertainty estimation
procedure
all three
intervals might have
absolutely no points in common
so
even though the patient belongs to each
of these three subpopulations in
question but the patient's diagnosis
will not
be in the intersection of these three
intervals
[Music]
so the difficulties of the type that
we've discussed
can actually be
talked about in a bit
more formal of a way
so how strong can our uncertainty
guarantees possibly be well ideally we
would like them to be conditional
conditional on
the patient's features
so if we were to
wish for
the most ideal
predictor ever we would of course pick
the base optimal predictor we would
predict the
expectation of the label conditional on
this current patient's features
and
for our prediction interval we would of
course
want its 95 certainty to be
as randomized over the labels
conditioned once again on this patient's
features
however
these guarantees are pretty much
unachievable especially when feature
spaces are
rich
for example
uh if you give me a patient with
features x i've probably never seen such
a patient
so i can't judge
the answer any of my predictions around
this patient's point
there's a statistical way out
kind of which is to
introduce a parametric assumption and
then
form uncertainty estimates around the
parameters of such an assumption uh
which will then translate into some
uncertainty estimates for our
predictions however what if we don't
want to make such
assumptions
then we might have to resort to
a more realistic type of guarantees such
as marginal ones
in this case we would be averaging over
the entire population instead of
conditioning on this particular
individual features so for example
instead of the bayes optimal predictor
we would be content with uh
just a calibrated predictor meaning that
we would want our prediction to coincide
with the expected true label conditions
on that prediction
in terms of
prediction intervals of course as we
just discussed we would want
to have marginal coverage intervals
which means that the 95 probability is
over the entire population
there's also another
problem
that
has been thwarting
greater and greater
uncertainty estimation advances which is
that
one often needs to make a lot of
distributional assumptions as it appears
for example in conformal prediction
there's a standard distributional
assumption called exchangeability which
roughly means that the future looks like
a pass
more formally it means that
data points can be swapped without
changing the distribution and this
assumption is actually only slightly
weaker than iid so it actually will fail
us in many many real life scenarios such
as for example time series data where
there can be correlations in the past
and the future
such as covariate shift imagine the
disease spreading through the population
and thereby altering
uh people's features so altering the
demographics
label shift so say we've come up with a
novel treat treatment for the disease
and so uh conditioned on a patient's
features the outcome will now change to
being more positive
and very sorts of strategic effects
consider
settings such as lending or hiring where
we might be employing a classifier to
decide uh which applications to select
and unless we frequently retrain our
classifier applicants
may
definitely consider
all sorts of manipulations uh to their
features
that would try to game the current
deployed version
so there's a lot of instability in the
um
real world and therefore
we may want to try and address that
so our work
indeed
aims to address these two challenges
outlined
first of all we give stronger than
marginal guarantees
our guarantees are essentially marginal
guarantees over
groups in potentially a large subset of
population groups
so um in the special case where the
entire population is a single group we
would require standard marginal
guarantees
and secondly we don't make any
distributional assumptions we'll be
working in a sequential adversarial
setting and so
data could be correlated could have
covariate shift effects could have label
shifts
and could have various sorts of
strategic effects we
don't care about that our guarantees
will hold in all of these settings
so
at this point
let me introduce the setting that we'll
be working in
we're giving a feature space x
and
we are provided with a collection of
groups subspaces of the fissure space
this collection of groups can be quite
large
and the different groups can overlap in
all sorts of complicated ways
our setting will be sequential we'll
proceed in rounds one through some large
time horizon big t
at each round the adversary first picks
a joint distribution over context
labeled pairs
x t y t
where we assume henceforth the labels to
come from the interval 0 to 1.
the learner only gets to observe the
realized context x t
and the learner does not get to observe
the conditional label distribution y t
given x t
so think of it as us being able to see
the patient and um
to look into the patient's condition but
not actually
uh being able to see
uh anything uh further about that
patient's diagnosis distribution
so what kind of predictions
do we want to make in such a case well
for example we may want to try and
predict the mean label
or we may want to predict the mean and
the cave moment of the label
such as the variance of the labels
or we may want to
predict at each round
a prediction interval
around these labels
finally having made the prediction we
now get to actually see the realized
label for this round so again the
setting is completely adversarial in
that if the adversary wanted to
he could potentially wait until we've
submitted our prediction and only then
determine
the distribution yt given xd
our plan now will be to jump into our
first application
um which is online multi-calibration in
the setting where we're predicting means
at each round we'll define it we'll then
show how to cast the interaction to the
learner and the adversary as a repeated
game will show that if the learner can
perform reasonably well in this game
then
um
we can obtain strong multi-calibration
bounds
and finally we will show how to
efficiently compute the learner's
optimal strategy at each round of this
game which will give us
um an implementation
of
an algorithm that actually achieves
these multi-calibration balance
so once again we predict the mean mu t
at each round
and
as customary when talking about
calibration let's partition the
learner's
strategy space so to say
zero to one into n sub intervals or we
call them buckets of equal sizes
roughly if mu t belongs to bucket i that
means that mu t is roughly i over n
regular calibration
is a requirement that for each bucket i
the average true label over those rounds
when the learner predicted
i over n or so
should actually also be close to i over
m
and a recent uh add-on to this
definition which has proven uh to be
quite fruitful
due to hebber johnson came around along
rothbloom is multi-calibration which
requires that we
should be calibrated not only over the
entire subsequence of rounds but also
over
each subsequence corresponding to
every group g
in
a family of population groups
so to define multicalibration formally
let us consider the following v
quantities
indexed by
the group the bucket and
the time point
so for any group g and bucket i
this quantity
actually describes
the extent to which
our
predictions
mu t
were close to the true mean
y t
over those rounds where first of all the
patient
or
the feature vector belongs to group g
and um secondly where our prediction
falls into bucket i
and so the requirement of
multi-calibration is that all these
quantities be small
formally we want to
ensure that one over t times the maximum
of the absolute values of these
quantities is at most some uniform
constant alpha
then we call our learner alpha n
multi-calibrated
so let's think about the structure of
this definition basically we're given a
bunch of constraints many of those
and these constraints are linear in the
realized labels y1 through it
so how do we actually
make sure that
the target objective is small
there is
a bunch of
hurdles that we'll need to deal with
before we can actually come up with an
efficient algorithm here they are first
off our objective is a max of a bunch of
things and analytically speaking it's
non-smooth and so
inconvenient to deal with
secondly
this objective actually takes into
account the entire history of the
interaction from around one through
round t
whereas
learners decisions
should come at each round and the
learner can't simply wait
um for any longer
and so uh the issue here is
to try and come up with a decision
scheme for the learner that is actually
algorithmically
tractable so not overly complicated such
as like taking into account all possible
future histories
and finally uh the most fundamental
change that at every round we're aiming
to predict the mean of a distribution
that we don't know anything about it's
adversarially selected how do we deal
with that
let's first
get rid of the first couple
problems here
first off let's instead of our original
objective
consider
a surrogate loss
known as soft max loss instead of the
max we're taking a sum of exponentials
with some parameter a that think of it
as one over root t
the soft max loss actually surprisingly
tightly approximates
uh our actual target objective so
henceforth will deal with this loss
and since it's smooth
we can now use the taylor expansion to
bound a quantity that we call delta t
this quantity represents the increase in
the loss from round t minus 1 to round t
and so for each round t we get some
bound on this quantity that contains
the learner's mu t the average series yt
and in particular previous rounds losses
so let's write this down
in a clearer form
basically at each round we can bound the
loss increments by
this expression where a and b can be
essentially treated as constant
which only depend on prior history but
not on
what the learner in the adversary will
do in the current round
if we can imagine that at all rounds the
learner
can get
the prediction muti close to the true
label yt
then we can imagine that all these
increments will be small and if the
increments are small then we can bound
the overall surrogate loss lt by using a
telescoping kind of argument
so
now we get to the answer to our second
question how to design a decision scheme
for the learner that's not too
complicated and that still achieves a
small multi-calibration loss will make
the learner greedy essentially at ground
t the learner will choose mt only with
the current round in mind
not caring at all about future rounds
the only objective around t in selecting
nu t will be to make the increments
delta t as small as possible so let's
focus the name around t and we'll see
that
the learner adversary interaction can be
naturally thought of as a two-player
game
where we are trying to
fight over this quantity that bounds
this round's last increments and the
learner wants it to be small goes first
and plays some ut potentially a
distribution over mu t and the adversary
wants to be large and goes next and
plays the label yt
so it looks like the learner is
disadvantaged here because
the adversary actually gets to see
the learner's action and potentially
could best respond to it
but a fundamental fact in game theory
tells us that this is not the case the
min max theorem for two player zero sum
games asserts that the order of play
doesn't actually matter
in fact even if
i go first i can still
find some strategy the mini max optimal
strategy
that will give me the best possible
thing i could hope for had i even gone
second
so to use this result we'll need to make
the learner's action set finite this is
just a technical restriction so the
learner will play multiples of one over
rn for some r
and so by this theorem despite going
first order has this strategy which
magically obtains the best possible
bounds on delta t
even though the learner goes second
and this might be as good as the learner
first got to see the adversaries label
but hold on if the if the learner knew
the adversary's label then
uh we could just get
one over two rn close to it by playing
the next grid points to
uh the adversary's choice of yt
therefore the minimax strategy
achieves this
even though
the learner actually goes first
so now we basically get a guarantee that
if the learner plays the minimax optimal
strategy then
uh delta t will be bounded by as small
number as we can possibly do
and so to unwrap this argument we now
plug this bound on delta t back into
the balance on
circuit loss
and that translates into
multi-calibration loss which gives us
our desired
existential guarantees and these look as
follows
basically we can get a high probability
bound as well as an expectation bound
over the randomness of the entire
transcript both these bounds essentially
say that alpha is
um
at most one over root t asymptotically
and
the dependence on the number of groups
in our family of groups is square root
of log
of the number of such groups
so first off of course we can't improve
the dependence on t because even in the
simpler distributional setting it's
known that we can't beat one over root t
in terms of calibration and secondly
we can actually
improve our dependence on the number of
groups even more for example if the
patients we've ever encountered between
rounds one and t are all
uh in at most d groups
for some d so each patient is only a
member of atmos d groups then we can
actually replace the size of the entire
family um of
these groups with d
which means that we can even
get
a good finite bound in the case where
our feature space is infinite and maybe
our family of groups is also infinite
okay
and now it turns out that there is
actually
an explicit
way for the learner to compute the
minimax optimal strategy at each round
in game theory typically
um
the
general recipes to solve a linear
program in order to compute such a
strategy but in this case we can
actually do an even simpler thing which
is displayed right here
so basically at each round we first
compute uh n quantities one for each
bucket that essentially represents our
performance on that bucket um in the
past and this is actually believe it or
not the bulk of the computational work
in this algorithm because we have to sum
over the groups that the current patient
belongs to
and now that we've computed these
quantities we just look at the three
possible cases related to these
quantities and in two of these cases we
end up predicting um with probability
one um
one
and zero respectively and in the third
case we will cleverly randomize over
just two of our grid points so therefore
not only is the algorithm simple
it is also
low randomization
which is pretty good
so now that we've taken a look at
multicalibration we'll briefly mention
another application in our paper called
prediction interval multiplicity which
is related in many ways to the conformal
prediction literature and improves on it
in some ways
and we'll briefly define it uh then show
that deriving existential
bounds in this setting is essentially uh
as simple as it is for multi-calibration
and it will display an efficient
algorithm
that lets the learner compute the
optimal strategies at each round
so at each round we'll now predict an
interval lt ut
and the bucketing will now work as
follows your interval is in bucket i
comma j if the left endpoint is in
bucket i and the right endpoint is in
bucket j
our goal will be as follows
we'll get a constant delta
think of it as 0.05
and our goal will be to predict an
interval such that the probability of
the label
being in that interval is 1 minus delta
think of it as 0.95
moreover it will require that this holds
conditional on each of the population
groups
in our group family
similar to multicalibration let's
consider the following v quantity is now
indexed
by g
i and j where i and j are buckets
for any g i and j such a quantity tells
us the following
that we should be
close in our coverage interval
uh to 1 minus delta
over
those rounds where first off the patient
or the feature vector belongs to the
group g and secondly our predicted
interval belongs to
bucket i j
and now you can possibly already guess
the definition of interval multiplicity
it is that one over t times the max of
the absolute values of these quantities
should be uniformly banded by some
constant alpha
and we'll need to make another technical
assumption here which is necessary um
that the adversary uh plays label
distributions that don't concentrate
overly on any given sub interval of zero
one this is just so that we can actually
get coverage uh approximately one
minutes delta
because if the adversary were to say
concentrate
the label at
one
then what would happen is that any
interval uh it's easy to check would
have coverage either zero or one so
never one minus delta
and how do we derive prediction interval
guarantees
we know the drill first switch to the
softmax loss with respect to these v
quantities then bound the one step
increments of this loss
using once again taylor expansions
next consider zero sum game at each
round where the payoff is the
obtained bounds on delta t the increment
then assume that the learner plays the
minimax optimal strategy in such a game
and then get existential bounds from
here once again via telescoping
why does this work here just as it did
in the multi-calibration setting well
because
suppose
we can flip by the minimax theorem um
the order in which the learner and the
adversary goes to suppose uh the learner
actually knew the adversary's label
distribution well we would just uh look
at the density curve for that
distribution and we would read off our
one minus delta prediction interval
quite easily
and so
uh
the last goal will be to give an
efficient algorithm for finding such a
minor x optional strategy
the existential guarantees as you can
see here are very similar looking to the
multi-calibration ones
and
the only question is how do we actually
achieve them algorithmically the
algorithm here is more complicated than
it is for multi-calibration here we
actually follow the already mentioned
standard template
for
solving for
minimax optimal strategies using
linear programs
in this case the linear program uh would
even be infinite size due to the
adversary strategy space being all zero
one
all of the distributions on that
uh and so our first step is to actually
reduce it down to this linear program
that you can see here which is actually
exponentially sized
and so for this linear program we cannot
really solve it in polynomial time
unless we have a good separation oracle
which we fortunately do it's based on
greedy knapsack packing
and so we use
the polynomial time ellipsoid algorithm
with this separation oracle to actually
find the optimal uh distribution of our
intervals for us to play at each rand
in conclusion we've presented
a general technique that allows us to
obtain stronger than marginal
uncertainty guarantees in an online
adversarial setting
in particular our guarantees hold
conditional on each group in a
potentially large and complicated set of
population groups
we provide both high probability and
expectation guarantees
and besides providing these guarantees
we actually also show how to
implement them in polynomial time
in fact subsequently we have discovered
that this framework can be further
generalized to cover
convex concave vector losses in general
online environments
you can see the paper at this link
and
this more general framework actually
allowed us to
not only recover multi-calibration
prediction rules and other uncertain
guarantees but also
very general no regrets algorithms
that in particular encapsulate
many known network frameworks such as
external internal adaptive et cetera and
we can also recover black
approachability on polytopes
in the future
there is still a lot of work to be done
first off we believe our results can be
extended without too much hard work
along a few practically important
directions first off
from binary so zero to one we might want
to extend this to multi-label settings
as well as maybe uh extend the
prediction intervals guarantees
to
what's known as prediction sets a
concept
being developed in the theory of
conformal prediction
secondly can the prediction errors
algorithm that we just presented be
implemented in a more practical way
of course it is polynomial time since
the ellipsoid algorithm is
but the ellipsoid is also very slow
finally
there is still a lot of work to be done
towards the experimental evaluation of
our algorithms and there's lots of
interesting questions such as for
example whether or not they empirically
perform much better or not
on distributional rather than worst case
adversarial data
and thank you very much for being with
me today
and i wish you a nice rest of your day
bye